quand est-il maintenant des
modifications au quotidien pourrons-nous
payer en euros existera-t-il des chèqus
ou des cartes bleu euros mode d'emploi
et réponse avec Émilie Lançon et Didier
ranur pour tout ce qui concerne l'euro
un grand principe celui du ni ni ni
interdiction ni obligation pour payer en
euros les deux parties doivent être
d'accord c'est un choix une mention
spéciale paiement en euros accepté
devrait bientôt voir le jour chez les
commerçants mais personne ne pourra
refuser vos francs jusqu'en 2002
pourra-t-on payer en euro à partir du
1er janvier oui mais uniquement par
carte de crédit ou chaque euro votre
actuelle carte bancaire vous permettra
d'effectuer indifféremment des paiements
en francs et en euros en conservant
votre code secret habituel en revanche
vous devrez commander un chéquier
spécifique et stampiller euros à votre
banque ces chéquiers sont gratuits et
vous pouvez en disposer même si votre
compte reste en francs vous pourraz
payer en euros dès le début janvier 99
sans avoir d'obligation d'ouvrir un
compte en euros et sans ces opérations
ne soient payantees pour vous peut-on
payer en euro dans les 11 pays de
l'union monétaire oui avec une carte de
crédit à condition qu'elle soit
internationale non avec le chèque euro
il y a très peu de chance qu'un
commerçant à l'étranger accepte ses
chèqus pour des questions de sécurité et
en plus ça coûte cher ça a coûteré entre
80 et 190 francs par chèque à chaque
fois qu'on fera un chèque ça sera cette
somme-là vos actions en bourse
resteront-elles côté en franc non vos
actions seront côtées en euros à partir
du 4 janvier mais vous pourrez continuer
à passer vos ordres en francs peut-on
régler ces factures en euros oui vous
pourrez payer vos cotisations sociales
en euro si vous le désirez vos impôts
par exemple les grandes entreprises
publiques EDF ou France Télécom se
mettent elles aussi à l'euro vos
factures vous paraîtront peut-être ainsi
un peu plus
légères